Salut, en ce moment j'enchaîne les
spectacles, les projets, les vidéos
et c'est le bordel chez moi un truc de dingue
qui est pas tout à fait logique parce que je suis
plutôt maniaque. Par exemple en anecdote rigolote pour
mon anniversaire j'ai commandé un
sèche-linge tu vois ? Le genre de cadeau que
tout le monde aime ça c'est vraiment fun
aujourd'hui je pense que la vidéo sera
un petit peu rapide ce qui est pas très
grave puisque les dernières étaient plutôt longues
mais c'est surtout parce que je viens de lire une série d'articles sur lequel
je pose pas forcément un avis très
construit mais j'aimerais bien partager
ça avec vous on va parler de l'effet
mouton chèvre. Générique
c'est un petit peu borderline parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va parler un petit peu
de psi mais pas de psychologie de... de
pouvoirs psi
ou de pouvoir potentiellement psi
c'est pas rare de voir des gens qui
prétendent avoir des pouvoirs psi ne
pas réussir à le faire quand on leur
demande ou dans des conditions de
laboratoire et la grande excuse
c'est de dire
oui mais là y'a des gens qui n'y
croient pas donc forcément ça... ça ne
fonctionne pas avec eux ils sont trop septique ils envoyent
de mauvaise énergie donc mon pouvoir ne peut pas se
mettre en place et on a l'impression
que c'est une bonne excuse pour tout
justifier tout et n'importe quoi en tout
cas pour les personnes rationnelles
comme moi je me dis c'est trop facile de
dire ça et puis là je suis tombé sur
un article et j'ai été faire un peu
plus de recherche je vous mets le lien
de toutes ces sources dans la
description si vous voulez dire ça vous
aussi et c'est intéressant ça ne me fait
pas forcément changé d'avis mais c'est
intéressant l'hypothèse serait que le
scepticisme soit donc une force mentale
et un pouvoir sur un résultat psi
Gertrude Schmeidler en 1957 a
tenté un test
oui on tente un test elle a testé un test  à New York où elle exerçait en
tant que professeur de psychologie à la
city university
elle a crée 2 groupes, 2 groupes
d'élèves
y a un groupe qui croyait aux pouvoirs
psi, à l'existence de ce phénomène et
un groupe qui n'y croyait pas du tout
qui était complètement sceptiques
y avait des élèves et y avait des gens normaux ce
qu'elle voulait c'était d'avoir
vraiment les convaincus d'un côté
et les rationnels
qui... qui refuse toute possibilité de pouvoir psi
de l'autre et pour son projet me
demandez pas pourquoi j'ai cherché
durant
une demi-journée je ne trouve pas pourquoi
elle a appelé ceux qui croyaient au
pouvoir psi les moutons et ceux qui n'y
croyaient pas les chèvres et elle a fait
passer aux personnes de ces groupes le
test de zener avec les cartes ESP
vous savez que les carte je vous en avais déjà parlé
donc y a le cercle,l'étoile
la croix le carré et les vagues juste
cinq symboles qui sont répété cinq
fois sur 25 cartes
et on prend l'une des cartes et la
personne en face celle qui est testé
doit deviné quelle carte on a dans  la main
on peut faire l'expérience ensemble
concentrez-vous quelle est celle que
j'ai dans les mains
j'ai d'après vous concentrez-vous j'ai
la vague une chance sur cinq
pour que vous ayez bon le test de
zener
ce fait un peu comme on veut par exemple
avec les 25 cartes et on note et on va
comparer avec ce qu'on aurais avec le hasard puisque ça peut être une chance sur
cinq d'avoir la carte plus il y a de cartes qui sont passé
plus on a de chance de trouver la bonne
carte etc ce qui est étonnant dans
les résultats de notre ami Gertrude
c'est que les moutons ceux qui croyaient
aux effets psi on eu des résultats
significatif c'est à dire de nombreux
succès plus que la lignée de base
du hasard alors que les chèvres les
rationnelle sont restés sur la
ligne de base du hasard
il n'y a pas eu de différence on a
donné un nom à cet effet c'est
rester sous le nom de l'effet mouton-chèvre
et en 1975 Marvin L Moon a
essayé d'améliorer un petit peu le
protocole de Gertrude je dis son
prénom à chaque fois que les noms de famille
sont compliqués je dis le prénom aprés et a
fait son propre test pour faire une
comparaison et les résultats ont été
un peu ouf puisque on a eu à peu
près les mêmes résultats que dans le
texte initial mais
y a une encore différence les
chèvres ceux qui ne croient pas du tout
dans les pouvoirs psi
on eu des résultats tellement mauvais
tellement de nuls tellement d'erreurs qu'ils
étaient en dessous largement en dessous
de la ligne de base du hasard c'est à dire
quand répondant au pif
on est censé avoir de meilleurs
résultats que ce qu'ils ont eu eux
une espèce de validation inversé
de leur propre croyance on peut lire ça
dans le journal of american
society
for psychological
Research je crois
je vous le met dans la description alors beaucoup de
personnes ont donné leur avis par
rapport à ça dont Eric Pigiani
mais ce sont des personnes qui sont
de base convaincu que le pouvoir psi
existe mais ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que les chèvres
fassent d'aussi bons résultats
dans leur croyance c'est à dire le
fait qu'ils ratent énormément
est une réussite en sois puisqu'il
ont défié le hasard pour aller sous la ligne de
base du hasard pour correspondre à ce
qu'ils pensent eux
le fait que ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
une réussite mais une réussite
inversé alors quel est mon avis
là-dessus me demanderez-vous je vous l'ai
dis au début de la vidéo j ai pas
forcément d avis dessus
surtout que j'ai pas pu dire plus de
choses que ça il faudrait voir ça
aujourd'hui
dans des conditions aujourd'hui des
conditions de labo voir ce que ça
représenterait peut-être que l'année
prochaine je ferais une vidéo là
dessus j aimerais bien reprendre ce test
faire peut-être appel à vous les
abonnés et faire un test dans ce sens
le but sera pas de prouver quoi que ce
soit mais de
reprendre le protocole nous même pour
le faire et voir ce que ça donne si
vous êtes partant sur l'idée
partant pour participer mettait le moi
dans les commentaires ces vidéos qu'on
pourrait se faire en janvier ou en
février encore une fois il aurait pas
de jugement particulier de croire ou pas
aux effets psi mais d'avoir deux
groupes de personnes qui pensent
différemment et de faire le test de
voir un peu ce qui se passe alors ça
vous tente comme toujours pensez à liker
la vidéo et à vous abonner si ça vous a
plus et rendez-vous demain à 17 heures
Tchao
j'aime bien attendre pour voir si il y en a qui reste un tout petit peu plus
longtemps jusqu'au bout du bout du bout
si c'est ça
alors vous êtes des vrais Tchao